(mouse clicking)
(beeping)
- For Chambers, and I know
we wish we could clone him
and bring him up to northern California.
We have tried over the
years, but it has not worked.
And we're gonna move into, into my world,
into the adult world, to
hear about some of the health
issues for adults with
cerebral palsy, Dr. Chambers.
- Thank you.
So, is this on?
So, one of my other areas
of interest, actually,
the other thing I do, half of my practice
is sports medicine.
So it's kind of a strange
thing, but I take care
of adults with cerebral
palsy and all disabilities
and I've been doing that
since the early nineties.
And one of the things I'm most proud about
in the cerebral palsy
academy is I got them to,
I got us to change our
mission statement to include
the lifespan, because there
was no scientific organization
that even studied problems
with adults with cerebral palsy
or other developmental disabilities.
So, I'm gonna just talk about
transitions in health care
and just using cerebral palsy as a model
because any other disorder
could work in this,
and you already have my disclosures,
so I won't go through that.
So, we all know the problem
and particularly in this
room I don't have to go
through, but you know
up until the age of 16
in some places care,
pediatric care stops
at 16 and in California
it stops at 21.
Our kids get the best care
they could possibly get.
We have the best pediatricians,
developmental pediatricians, neurologists.
Our CSS system in California is fantastic,
and then, and we have
great Shriner's systems.
We have great children's
regional hospitals.
I mean, things are fantastic,
and then you turn 21
and you just drop off the
cliff and we all know that
that's the problem.
(laughing)
I have an amen from this corner.
So, once again I told you I'd
have a little hint of this,
that I thought that we're
taught that cerebral palsy is
a non progressive brain
disorder and I have seen enough
changes in my adult population
that I'm not quite sure
that that's true.
I've seen people develop
Parkinson's like symptoms
when they're in their twenties.
I've seen MRI changes in the brain
but people have,
neurologists have told me,
well, that's just
because they have changes
in the circulation of
the cerebral spinal fluid
and that's why it looks bad.
But there are actually some changes.
So I'm not quite sure that that's true,
because remember all the people
that made these definitions
are pediatricians, and
they don't follow them
into adulthood and don't
know what's going on.
So I mean, the last time I
found a really good thing
on the round table of
aging and cerebral palsy
was a long time ago.
But they brought up
the same problems that,
we haven't solved any of these, and we're,
and so I think there's nothing new in this
about exercise.
We talked about some
women's issues yesterday,
how we provide the quality of care.
Nutrition's a huge problem.
Many of my adult patients
are either undernourished
or overnourished.
We have medical conditions
that are, that we all have,
heart disease, hypertension,
that just get worse with age
that we just ascribe to
people having cerebral palsy.
Communication becomes
harder as you get older
if your parents aren't there
to help interpret for you
or if you're living in a
group home or some other
living situation where
people can't understand what
you're talking about.
The psycho social aspects
of aging that we all have,
and then, and then economics.
We'll talk about some of these.
So, there are many more
people with chronic conditions
that are living past the age of 18.
We all know that.
There's no surprise.
As I told you earlier,
there are more adults
with cerebral palsy
than there are children.
I try to make this argument
to the dean of my medical
school all the time.
He goes, well,
but the answer that the
department of medicine told me,
but aren't they all on Medicaid?
And I go, well, yeah.
Well, we don't wanna see them, so,
and that's exactly what happens.
And so, we have all of
these patients that are now
living, you know, things like
people with muscular dystrophy
didn't use to live.
We have much better care,
and now we have adults
with muscular dystrophy we
don't know what to do with.
And, you know, if we look
at the life expectancy
of able bodied North Americans, you know,
in 1900 it was 47 years old.
In '95, it's 76 years old,
and there's, you know, so if you're 65,
if you were age 65 in 1995 you
have 17 more years to live.
It's a lot, it's a lot more than that now.
I can't believe I didn't
change that slide.
But life expectancy in Down Syndrome
if you were born in 1929 your
average life was nine years,
because of the heart disease, mainly.
That was how long people lived,
and if you were born
in 1989 it's 56 years.
So I still get calls from
cardiologists who are,
adult cardiologists, friends of mine,
who have a person with Down
Syndrome show up in their office
and they go, I have never seen
a person with Down Syndrome.
I don't even know what's going on.
But you guys saved him.
I mean, our cardio
thoracic surgeon saved him.
You guys saved him, and
what am I supposed to do?
And I go wow, it sounds
like you have a problem.
(audience laughing)
But that is, but it is a
problem because we don't know,
there's a lot of things
that we just don't know
the natural history of,
and as we do more and more
keeping children alive
we don't know what to do.
I just took care of a child
who was cured, truly cured,
of Tay Sachs disease.
They have no, the enzymes are
completely back, stem cells,
completely neurologically devastated,
and I have no idea what
to do for this kid.
I mean, there's no natural history.
His hips are dislocated
and it was becoming painful
and it put them back in, but I don't know
what they're gonna, how
they're gonna do this,
and then every one of
these genetic problems that
we have no idea what
the natural history is
is gonna be a challenge for us.
And so, one of the big,
if you're just looking
at cerebral palsy in general the big
determinant of how long they're gonna live
often depends on whether they have
a seizure disorder or not.
So, it may be because they aspirate
or because that means
there's a more severe CP,
but if you don't have a
seizure disorder it seems like
your life expectancy is
probably 10 to 15 years longer.
But no one's exactly sure what that is.
So the mean now is about 60 years old.
So we have a long time,
40 years, of kids who have
no real, oh, kids, I
guess they're kids now.
They're younger than I am.
But that are, we have
people that are living 'til
they're 60 and that have
no care during that time,
or very poor care, and
that's where the problem
with the access to medical care.
So, and I think some of the problem is
the way we train our physicians.
We train the people who take
care of the primary care
problems as pediatricians or internists
and then there's family
practitioners who are supposed
to span that gap and there
are now med peds people
that do that, but almost
all the med peds people
that I talk to don't get into this
to take care of people with disabilities.
There's other, they have
other interests than that
including our university at UCSD.
And so, and this really, I
was kind of joking around
with our dean about what our dean said
but it's totally true.
The reimbursement for this is so poor
and I can't, I really can't
blame a internal medicine
doctor who has no
training in cerebral palsy
or developmental disabilities
and having someone
in a wheelchair with 20 medical problems
and problems with cerebral
palsy come into their office
for the $19 that they get for that
and it's really, I can't blame anybody.
But it's a shame on our
society, not a shame on them,
and you know you get a
six dollar for a return
visit with MediCal.
I don't know if you know that,
how well you get reimbursed
as a doctor, and then the
problem with the durable
medical equipment.
How do we get it?
And I think someone mentioned
it in the CCS talk is
when they're in CCS they're taken care of.
They get, you get the
equipment that's all,
but once you're out of
that you're in Medicaid
and it's tough to get the equipment.
Transportation becomes a
bigger problem as (laughs)
I get a lot of--
(audience laughing)
I guess that's a no kidding, huh?
And it really is true.
You probably don't appreciate that,
but people that have jobs in California,
at least in San Diego, I
can't, maybe I can't speak
for California, you have
to call the bus every day.
You have to say, you need
to pick me up tomorrow
some time between eight
and 12 or something,
whenever they say they're gonna show up.
Or you may not get a ride at all, yeah.
So that's exactly right,
and so transportation
is a real problem, and then
access to doctor's offices
is really bad.
My son sees a psychiatrist
who is totally embarrassed
that he doesn't have access to his place.
So he comes to the house for house calls.
There's not many psychiatrists
that do house calls
but then I pay him cash so
he probably doesn't like,
there's--
(audience laughing)
It's probably a different reason.
And that comes to access
to mental health care.
So as I told you a little bit
earlier in my adult clinic
I have a very high incidence
of mental health issues
that are totally unaddressed.
I have a hard time getting
people to see them,
to see people with
problems, and then there's
communication issues and
some of the things we talked
about yesterday with the sexuality issues
and gender issues are also, have problems.
There's the social stigma
of mental illness on top
of having mental illness,
there's that problem,
and then problems with
compliance with medication,
which is true of all people
that have bipolar disorder
for example or depression.
You know, the medication side
effects are really terrible.
So my son has bipolar disorder
and some of the side effects
of the medications are dystonia
tardive dyskinesia, right?
So you've already got that,
let's make that worse.
So that's not so good.
And then the quality, once again,
we just don't have physicians
that know what they're doing.
We talked about dental
care access yesterday
and I've had two patients
die of dental abscesses.
So I've taken care of
them their entire life.
They get an abscess they aspirate
and they get a multi bacteria,
multi microbial bacterial
infection that can't be taken
care of with antibiotics,
just 'cause no one brushes their teeth.
In San Diego, I've actually
talked to our regional center.
It's okay in group homes if
they don't brush their teeth,
they just stick the stuff in
their mouth like Listerine
or something and that's
all they have to do.
But we all know that
that doesn't do anything
and but that's what they have to do now.
And once again, most
of our medical care is
accessed through the emergency room.
So the general health
issues are, you know,
here's the dental, the dental stuff,
and this is where it came down to.
So they don't get their dental hygiene.
When their parents are around they do,
but once they get into a
different living situation
they may not get even on a
weekly basis their teeth cleaned.
Exercise, something
that we all need to do.
It's important for aging
and how many adults
with disabilities do we
have do aerobic exercise?
None, right?
I mean, it's really
hard to do it and it's,
and even the people at GMFCS, you know,
if you're at GMFCS three you get plenty
of aerobic exercise, 'cause you're using,
you're using your walker and stuff,
but the people that are,
you know, as you get older
and you have a sedentary
job like many of us do
you sit around, you're not, the last thing
after you're totally
exhausted from walking around
on crutches is to come home
and do some of the exercises
and with it we don't even
really have any guidelines.
We talked about this
yesterday and I think this is,
there's no reason to bring this up.
I do know that in my
adult clinic I'm the one
that sets up all of theses appointments.
I'm a pediatric orthopedic surgeon.
I mean, you gotta, this is,
(audience laughing)
this is really bad.
So, I set up the PAP smears
and I set up the breast,
you know, the mammograms,
and have discussions
with menopause with my older patients.
So, I'm the wrong person, no, no, no,
I'm the wrong person to be doing that.
There's no clapping there.
There's something wrong with that.
You don't want that.
And we talked about nutrition,
overweight and underweight,
and one of the most common
causes of death in adults
with cerebral palsy is
aspiration and choking.
And you lose, people do lose function.
They have the pseudobulbar palsy.
Any medication that they
take, if you have reflux
from being overweight or
just as you get, you know,
those of us, you get
older, you get reflux.
It could actually be a life
threatening problem in adults
and especially if you're
fed in a nursing home
where people are just chewing,
putting stuff in your mouth.
It doesn't really matter if
you're swallowing it or not,
and once again, if you
have no teeth, your teeth
are all rotten, your nutrition gets worse.
And so, as you get older,
as all of us get older,
our lungs become less
strong and so that alters
your speech patterns and
so it's more difficult
to understand.
And then everything that
adults have as you get older
people with cerebral palsy
who are people get as well,
and so, and these are all these problems.
But things are just,
people just miss these,
and osteopenia, we had
a little bit bit of,
somebody mentioned some things
about fragility fractures.
You know, they are a little
bit higher but not as much
as I thought they would be.
I don't take care, I
would say I see as many
fragility fractures in
children as I see in adults.
So I'm not, I don't think
it's that huge of a problem,
mainly because a lot of
times if you're spastic
even though you're not
standing your bones aren't
particularly that bad, which
is a little bit of a surprise.
Substance abuse is a
problem with our patients,
with our adult patients.
I'll have to say it's a little bit worse
since January first.
I have a lot of people showing
up stoned to my clinic.
(audience laughing)
But that's just my nurses.
So, no, but this is
becoming a little bit more
of a problem.
But some of the, some
of the, so once again,
don't miss those.
Things that do get worse over
time and I've seen this are
seizure disorders get
worse as you get older.
We have early onset dementia
and I think that's either,
there's a talk coming out, yeah.
So there's early onset dementia
and early onset Alzheimer's
in people with cerebral palsy.
I've seen, I'm telling you
I've seen some patients
with early Parkinson's
disorder, which actually
have been treated well
with deep brain stimulation
which also helped their
dystonia a little bit,
but dystonia gets worse throughout life.
Once again, these problems are worse
in adults with cerebral palsy
and the vision problems are, once again,
I told you, remember, the vision problems
because of field cuts.
Those field cuts can progress through life
and people lose their vision
and then it's often difficult,
who knows, if you haven't
monitored it throughout
their life you don't really
know if that's just part
of aging or you know just
the normal loss of eyesight.
And then I see, you see
more reflux and more dental
problems as people get older.
Like all of us we have declining mobility
and it's magnified in
people with cerebral palsy.
That GMFCS those curves
that I showed you, you know,
about the, I don't know if you noticed.
They had three ages.
One was six to 12, 12 to 18,
and then the 19 through 23
and that's as far as they've gone out.
You, actually people lose function.
So you from a three to a four, a four,
rarely a four to a five, but
you go from a two to a three
meaning you're using,
you're just using AFOs.
The next thing you do,
you're using a walker
and then that group can
drop down as they get older
into wheelchairs.
I think we all know that.
You've seen it happen.
Probably even your older
teenagers where that happens,
because it's more convenient.
It takes so much energy
and life to get through
but then there's having
a wheelchair is not
the easiest thing in the world.
But we all have decreased
endurance as we get older
and that's a problem.
The other thing that I see
in people that didn't even
really have problems before
is that you start having
early arthritis and because
your joints don't go through
a full range of motion,
whether it's your hip
or your knee or your ankle
these things break down fast.
So if you take your
knee and just go through
a range of motion like this, just going,
that's all you're,
that's all you're doing,
though at that area of
your knee wears down
and it's particularly
the patella femoral joint
and so we have some
real problems, you know,
in 30 and 40 year olds
having arthritis that
I see in 60 year olds, you
know, we see in 60 year olds
typically developing people.
And the spine gets worse, too.
A lot of back pain.
I would say most of my
adult clinic is pain
and that's what we're seeing
and trying to figure out
why that is and is there any
role for orthopedic surgery?
We don't really know.
So the other, the other
problem is if you have
athetoid CP which is actually
less than a, you know,
that was very common back
in the fifties and sixties
before we realized about
hyperbilirubinemia.
A lot of adults had this
choreoathetosis movement
with normal mentation.
And you'd see people walking
down the road, you know,
and having a hard time talk,
but when you talk to them
there was no other problem,
and when they sat down
and weren't moving around
they didn't have problems.
But this, the constant
movement of your neck
either with athetosis or
with dystonia for example
can cause spurs that I
have a patient that one
of the bone spurs cut
the spinal cord in half
and people watched this guy
get worse and worse and worse
and said oh, he's got CP.
And so, his spinal cord
was cut in half at C seven.
And so, these are, and so you get these
and you also can get ruptured
discs that people miss
and that's what, this is from the motion.
And also, as we all get
older, our muscles waste.
It's sarcopenia.
Sorry, you're all wasting away right here,
and that's why we have to lift weights
and that's an important
part of, it's not just
for orthopedic surgeons, okay?
Just remember that.
You have to lift weights.
And the other thing
that we see is many more
skin breakdowns, skin ulcers.
Once again as you get old,
or when you're young you can
do a lot of things.
You sit in the same
position and you can't move
your body around you get
skin breakdown pretty easily
and you think of, you
know, you can think of your
90 year old grandparents
who, you know, when they hit
the wall or something
their skin just flakes off
and it happens sooner in
people with cerebral palsy
because they're always
sitting in the same position.
And so we see a lot of that.
And so here's someone that
came to me and had a lot
of, I guess that light,
I don't know how to turn
that light down.
I don't know if you can
see it but he was having
swallowing problems.
First of all, he had a
spinal cord stimulator
which was supposed to help his spasticity.
Obviously nobody does that
anymore, but that was the idea.
But he couldn't swallow and
he had a swallowing test
and they said everything was negative,
and I don't know if you
can see right here but his
vertebral bodies are twice
as wide as the other ones.
It's right there and I actually
looked at the swallowing
study and it goes right
there and it goes bloop
and comes right back out.
So, that was a very simple
solution, well, surgery,
but it was a simple solution
and that we just had
to take those spurs off and
he was able to swallow right
away and he actually gained
10 pounds and so it was
a really, but you just
have to look for it,
and that's the question.
So as I said, chronic pain
is the biggest problem that
I have and so there's the
botulinum toxins, oral medication,
and I forgot to add it on
there but I really do think
there's a role in the
cannabinoids, marijuana.
(audience laughing)
But, but, you know, the CBD
thing I think there's gonna be,
you know, it doesn't
have to be the THC part
where you get high but maybe
impair your, yeah (laughs).
Sounds good, huh?
(audience laughing)
But also, but so, I
think there's gonna be,
I think, I hope that we'll be
able to study this some day.
All things must end.
Pain medications are a real problem,
especially with the opioid overuse.
Probably the biggest problem.
I've rarely seen adults
that are opiod dependent.
It certainly could be possible
but the biggest problems
that the realize right
away is constipation.
They already have constipation
and that's the last
thing they wanna add to their life.
All these other things,
massage, chiropractic,
healing touch.
My wife's a healing touch practitioner.
I think those are all really important.
My wife comes to all of my CP clinics
particularly my adult clinics.
They love seeing her
and they hate seeing me.
(audience laughing)
And doing wheelchair
modifications for pain
is really important for
the therapist to take,
to look at.
You change.
I mean, we all know they
change through adolescence
just 'cause of their
growing, but as you get older
your weight changes either up or down.
If you have a little
scoliosis and it curves just
a little bit more and
you don't need surgery
but you have to change
your chair and once again
those skin issues and I
would say I was doing so much
of this that I hired a
physiatrist just to do my adult,
do my adult care and it
really is, that's fantastic.
So she spends a lot of time,
frequent changing of positions.
The psycho social issues,
we talked about that.
75% of adults even the
GMFCS three and above
are independent in ADLs,
but then that means
that more aren't.
30% still live at home with their parents.
I saw a 67 year old whose 87
year old mother brought him in.
That's not good for any
of those two people.
Once again, high incidence of depression,
low self esteem, and I talked
about these depressive things.
So transition from home
to community, we have to,
you know, as doctors
and providers, you know,
what's available for people?
You know, do they stay at home?
Do they move into residential facilities?
What are the community based
programs that are available?
And unfortunately, in our
place we've actually looked
at all of them.
They're on our website, but
they're not easy to find.
All these programs are not out there.
Even us looking for them and
knowing where to look for it
they're hard to find.
Do they go into an
intermediate care facility,
which we hope would be the
worst place that they could go.
Community homes, there are
some great community homes
and there are some really
bad community homes.
You know, after watching
that ACLU thing yesterday
I was thinking of how some of
things are just rife for that.
Supported living, I think
this is a really good option.
Independent living, my son's
actually in supported living.
So he has, we bought a house for him
and then he has people coming
in to care for him 24 hours
a day and you know we see him
four times a week but we don't
have to do the care, which you don't want
your parents to be doing that.
There are some people who
can live independently
and sometimes to have the people come by
and just checking on them
and seeing how they're doing.
The transition from school
to work, you know, as we,
the public schools, once
again, they're just like us.
Once you're done, you're done, sorry.
We do have programs that go up to 21.
In San Diego it's called
the Trace program.
I don't know, do you have
that here in, same thing?
Okay, and so I think those are
really good for transition.
College, we have the young woman who went,
got her masters, and those
are all, those are options.
So obviously much more
complex and we help support
many patients in San
Diego who go to college.
We talk to their counselors
and we provide all their,
they're not IEPs or but
they're, they're similar to that
for the colleges.
Vocational training, it
seems like we used to do
a lot of this.
It seems like there's less of this now,
but I think that's the thing we can go.
We talked about the unemployment rate.
Most people receive government stipends.
That's at risk right now as
you've seen some of the bills
before Congress.
We gotta pay for those tax cuts
and that's where it's gonna come from.
I was just in Louisiana last week.
I guess I could be
political in San Francisco.
I was just in Louisiana last week
and they, you know, they like
Kansas cut all their taxes
and the very first thing
they cut was all the services
for disabled children and adults.
It was on the front
page of the paper there,
just the day before yesterday, so, and,
so that's where we're,
that's where we're headed.
So, getting jobs are really important
and we're involved in that
and helping people get jobs.
We work through the regional
center as much as we can
but there's, you know, just
regular competitive employment
like we all have, supported
employment where there may be
someone coming to help someone go to work,
giving a job coach, and
these are, there's very few
of these left, these day
programs and sheltered workshops.
In some way that's positive,
and in some ways it's negative
and some of the positive
ways it gets, it forces
the individual with the
disability to be in the community.
It forces our, well, it
encourages our people that have,
that are employers to have
people with disabilities
but that doesn't always work.
But the sheltered workshops
were just another way
to isolate and segregate our
people with disabilities.
And so I don't really
have a thought about that
but I know we're seeing fewer of them.
And so the transition from
adult, pediatric to adult
health care, a lot of it
has to do with insurance.
So, the whole the Medicare act
was set up, Medicare MediCal
CMS type thing, was set
up to have this dichotomy
at age 18 or 21 and so that was set up
in the sixties, and that's the problem.
So why don't we have CCS for life?
And why, where does that come from?
We give them just the best care at all.
It's the same money, same
trunk of money comes from
the, you know, the state.
One goes to Medicaid
instead of going to CCS
and why not keep that great program going
and I've talked to our legislator.
You know, the one thing
about term limits is
your legislators don't know
anything about anything.
Right?
(audience laughing)
I mean they, you know,
it's just, it's terrible.
But I'm not, I don't know
if that's right or not.
But they don't know anything.
They don't even know what CCS is.
So, once again, the mental health issues
are a real problem as far
as how do we get anybody
to take care of those patients.
We want our adults to have
real choices in all aspects
of life, have, provide functional skills,
not just what you've
learned in high school.
These are actually from
adults with cerebral palsy,
what they want.
You want to have an interaction
with a variety of people.
You want to be just in generic services.
You don't have your own
special little place to go.
You wanna, don't go,
you wanna go to the YMCA
or the JCC across the street.
You know, have access
to community resources,
a range of community environments not just
the one place where you get to go.
You wanna live in a typical neighborhood
not in a little isolated place.
Doing what we all do, you
have to have something to do
every day, and if you
don't you don't survive.
It's one of the reasons that people retire
and if they don't have anything
they don't last very long.
You wanna have non
adversarial interactions
instead of having to fight
for everything that you have
in your life, have
friends, and that brings up
these issues, and we
talked about sexuality
and self esteem yesterday.
I took a lot of these slides out.
And we talked about the
competency yesterday
about how that's a civil
right that can be taken away
and why they don't take it seriously.
Now I might have disagreed
a little bit with the,
I'm forgetting her name, it was so great.
Anyways, oh, not the public defender.
I wasn't there for that one.
The person from the ACLU, Susan.
Anyway, she said that it's
hard to get your rights back.
Well every three years
my son, we have to take,
my son has a lawyer and
we have to take a lawyer
and we go to court.
It's not messing around stuff.
So it's obviously very
expensive, 'cause I have to pay
for both lawyers, but--
(audience laughing)
But we still have to go to court
and have the discussion.
Has anything changed?
And so, I think our judges
in San Diego take it
very seriously 'cause they
realize you're taking away
people's civil rights.
So, our population with
disabilities is growing rapidly.
We know little about the
natural history of these
disabilities and I'm kind of guilty.
The only people that come
to my clinic are people
that have a problem.
So I don't know what my denominator is.
I know what my numerator is.
It's 5100 patients, but I don't
know what my denominator is
and so they, those other
people may be doing great
or they just can't get in to see us
and so I don't know what
the natural history is.
So we need to do research and there's no,
I can guarantee you, there's
no money, I've tried,
in this area.
We need to educate our medical students
and other health care
providers in adult care, amen,
another amen, and that
needs, that could start now.
There's no reason why that
can't be done right now.
It's kind of crazy, and
then our, we have to have
you know a health maintenance organization
other than just a way for money to be put.
This is a perfect position for an HMO,
whether it's a state run HMO or whatever,
and I know we have that
opportunity but I guarantee,
the people, there was a thing
that people with Medicaid
had to be in an HMO and I lost
about a half of my patients
whose parents call me every
day going there's no one
in this HMO that knows how to take care
of someone with disability,
and you probably
have run into that too.
So I see them for free,
but there's not many other
people that can do that.
And so what are the solutions?
And Clarissa, I don't
know if she's here today,
'cause I don't usually
give this talk to you all,
because I stole her stuff.
You're supposed to hide
where you steal stuff from
but I stole it from her
from this conference
when I came a couple
years ago, and her thing,
this ITOP, improving
transitional outcomes,
is, you know, provider
competency, access to quality
health care, patient
support, quality assurance
and oversight, public
engagement and support,
and you can see it's very
similar to what she did
in the adapt, was it adapt?
Aspire, aspire yesterday, to, you know,
for children and families with autism.
So how we, we need to train
and mentor these people.
It's hard to find mentors
'cause there's not many around
that know anything about it
and the use of electronic
health records so they can
be transferred from place
to place I think is really important.
It's the bane of my existence,
electronic health records.
I hate it, but it's great,
when they're done well.
It's just an extra two hours
at the end of every one
of my days, and then the
barriers whether it's exam rooms
or how families, how people
get access to information
and longer appointment times.
That was brought up this morning,
and then, and provide, and
have specialized doctors,
specialists who will be
able to see these people.
So, how do we get this information out?
Well, the computer is great
but many people can't,
many people with CP either
don't have access to a computer,
they don't have high speed internet.
You know, going to the library,
certainly not the easiest
thing in the world to get
to to get this information,
and so I think that's
gonna, that's a real,
that's a barrier for people.
We talked a little bit
about the language barrier,
not having all these
information in Spanish.
Half my patients are Spanish speakers,
so it's really hard now to do that.
How do we get the, how do
you reimburse the doctors
and the health facilities so they'll be,
wanna take care of this?
How do we change our transportation?
You know, the clinicians,
those, there's, I'm lucky.
I have residents and fellows
and nurse practitioners
and PAs and all those.
I have tons of help.
But most people are by themselves.
There are many, many primary care doctors
that are by themselves,
and you can't expect them
to see someone, you know,
if you see five patients
with disabilities and you make $29 a visit
that's not a very good day.
It doesn't even turn on the lights.
And then, can we provide health
care in natural settings?
Can we have ways to have
mobile vans to go around?
And I think those are all possibilities.
Education for our patients
and their families
and people who are caring for them.
Who, who makes, who helps make decisions?
This is gonna be, this is
a real, a real question
and I think this is something
Clarissa has looked at.
How do we teach our caregivers?
I mean, my son has 12 caregivers.
They make the minimum wage and you know
I'm trusting, that's a lot of trust.
That's why we're over there
four or five times a week.
But most people don't
have advocates like we are
and then when we die who's gonna be there?
I mean, I'm assuming,
I'm hoping I'm not gonna
outlive my son.
My son's gonna outlive
me, and then coming up
with a health care plan for every person
and that's very, very
similar to what road block
that Clarissa talked about yesterday.
I mean road map, not road block.
We do have road blocks, but a road map.
And then just the quality
assurance to make sure
we're doing good things for people.
And then, you know,
educating the public on that
this is a real problem and
once again we're all gonna
be disabled at some point,
and so when people are going,
well, what do I care about
someone with a wheelchair?
Well, you might be in one
someday, or what do I care,
and it's also the thing that you've seen.
So when I was, you know,
just starting out all the,
in pediatric orthopedics
all the parents came
in those umbrella strollers, right?
And now they've got those SUV double wides
with DVD players built in them
and all that kind of stuff.
So that's because we have curb cuts, so.
So, we wanna develop a shared
vision of responsibility
that we're champions and
then this is where our,
one of our responsibilities
and we're the only people
that can do this is to
educate our lawmakers
and having done that some time it's,
it's kind of interesting.
It's fun and you learn
a lot, but you realize
if you don't have a checkbook with you
no one wants to talk to
you, and I did learn that.
That was quite a, it's kind of cool to be
in the halls of Congress
'cause you see it on TV
all the time but realize
that you're nothing.
And then look at the
different, different models
and this is where the real
problem is is, you know,
we educate primary care specialists
and it's not gonna be
pediatricians 'cause pediatricians
don't wanna take care of 60 year olds.
That's why they're pediatricians.
The family practitioners
possibly, but they,
I haven't found them to
be a very interested group
in this area.
I'm getting ready to
hire a med peds person
but I'm having a hard time finding one
that is interested in
it because once again
you don't get paid very much to do this,
this really complex work, and it's really,
and it's hard stuff.
Universities should be
able to take this on.
They have residents and
fellows and it'd be a great way
but and once, my
university at UCSD does not
want to see more than 7% Medicaid.
That's their goal, and
I don't know what to say
and that's just, that's
just the way it is.
So, that's why I see all these patients.
We need to get some lifespan physicians
and I think that's possibly coming
and I think as we start doing things in
our CP academy and some
of our schools that
this might happen.
You know, it's interesting
in Europe, the way that,
at least in orthopedics, when
they take care of a child,
say that, a hip problem.
So an orthopedic surgeon
will take care of the newborn
hip with DDH and will also
put the total joint in.
They take care of it
through the whole lifespan
and we don't even do that
in the United States.
We stop, the same thing.
We have adult and pediatric providers.
And so, as you transition
through life, these are my last,
I'm back to cartoon, so now I can
understand what's going on.
(audience laughing)
So, you know, when you
bring your child home from
the hospital you've got these
things they're worried about.
You have all the agencies.
You have CC, and all
these, CCS, what does all
this stuff mean?
MediCal, all these things.
You have all these, people
are talking about PDAs
and necrotizing enterocolitis
and all these words
you've never heard of.
Your family's thrown into an upheaval.
You have other children and
then you have financial,
you know, financial
problems on top of that.
You have to buy a van, you
have to buy these things
and then as they get older
you have to worry about
what they do for leisure.
You have to do this IEP for, I mean,
this is technology.
So buying those iPads, no
one's paying for those.
Getting the, your big van
to get people somewhere.
Education, I had to do an
IAP every year for my son,
or I mean I had to, I had to
threaten to sue the school
district every year 'til he
graduated from high school.
I mean, I mean, seriously.
I mean, I just bring in
the law and I drop it down.
I go, I know how to read the law,
and I got to go, it's the same
principle, same everything.
So think of parents that aren't
sophisticated how hard that is.
And then, I'm not saying
I'm sophisticated,
but I know how to read the law, and then,
and then social interactions,
how do your kids
have to, how do you
get them to have be out
with their friends?
I mean, that's, you
know, it's really hard.
Then, you know, when I talked about jobs,
everybody wants to have a job.
Everybody wants to some self worth
and then we start talking about self care
and self advocacy and
I'm really proud my son
has really gotten into that.
He advocates for himself all the time
and we say you should do this, he said no,
and that's good.
(audience laughing)
Where do you live?
Where do you live, and we
talked about that just now.
Conservatorship, we've talked about it.
That's come up several
times and this group
certainly understands it more than most.
But then we get in it to
adults and we just talked
about the problems with
medical care for adults.
We're all getting older,
parents are getting older.
It's hard to take care of your kids
and especially as they, you
know, my son weighs 120 pounds
and I, my wife's a lot stronger than I am,
but she lifts him all the
time, but it's really hard,
and then I have a lot of
patients now who are retired.
So they've had a job.
They retired age 55.
They worked in the postal
service for example.
All their friends are gone.
Their whole social thing is gone
and they're very depressed.
It's a very tough time for these people
and so the last slide and finally
this is why you're all here.
This is why I'm here.
This is why we do these things
and we're all these people
here that are holding
up this giant triangle
of all the things that happen
for people with disabilities
and look at what's the
smallest part on this thing,
is medical up there.
This is the most important thing.
All these other things are
the most important things.
So thank you very much for inviting me
and we're gonna have a little--
(audience applauding)
Thanks.